oui des toutes premières enfin oui c'est
la mairie qui vous lie à l'aller la la
la la
alors moi je prête ma voix à max tient
base duke un bain aux mets c'est
terrible c'est un peu le petit chien
cool on aime bien la voix remporte un
peu un peu leader ouais une minute tu as
peut-être un peu loin là non tout va se
compliquer le jour où sa maîtresse va
pas ramener un chien la fois ya qui
s'appelle duke tout va partir en vrille
ça c'est mon appart maintenant et mon
petit ligne ou duke c'est un gros chien
ouais on les affuble à ses vrais pb
zigouille a pas tenues il est pas tout
il a s'impose en quoi il se rend pas
compte qu'il est un peu lourdingue quoi
pour chaque mètre que j'ai tué si
j'avais reçu un dollar je mets un dollar
voilà j'ai tué que celui là vous êtes
sans pitié
mon personnage s'appelle poupe avantage
attention la série a passé d'accord il
est très beau tout petit mais il est
complètement dingue
donc en fait c'est même pas un rôle de
composition pour moi oh je t'en prie tu
vas pas commencer chloé ce que je
voudrais c'est que tu m'aides map ça va
tu tombes
c'est une chatte elle est obèse hockey
et en tant qu'ami je vais être franche
avec toi je me fiche pas mal de
problèmes elles se sont très supérieurs
aux chiens ce qui est tout à fait normal
venons d'achat j'ai un plan tout est
détaillé les accus super rythme ça fuse
sont des films qui parlent absolument à
tout le monde et de petits messages que
je sens tout ça je suis très mignon pour
les enfants jeux sympas bebek d'un
actionneur un drôle caustique